hey guys my name is Heinrich and welcome
to affirm learning I'm a little bit
excited because this is my very first
video on this channel and I would like
to use it as an introduction of what you
can expect if you subscribe to my
channel and look at all the future
videos that I'm going to upload
I'm Heinrich I'm from Germany and my
passion has always been business and
management I would like to use this
channel to reflect on my experiences and
share what I have learned in the last
year's my professional background is
management consulting I've worked for
over 6 years for large leading top
management consulting firm and now
recently transitioned to a role in
industry now working for a large German
fashion retailer this channel is going
to be especially targeted towards new
people just being in the labour market
for couple of years young professionals
or people who are going to join the very
first job they're going to have very
soon some things I recover are for
example meeting behaviour how can I
behave at the very best in the meeting
if I'm only a junior colleague or having
tough conversations with some alum work
colleagues or maybe even my boss or what
it would to make a mistake at work what
you do about it
I do that but also topics covering
mindset issues and other things that
might hold you back in order to be
successful in your career before working
a standing business and philosophy here
in Munich but also in other universities
across Europe these have been some
pretty formative years for me as well
which were not also heavily influenced
how I see things what my perception is
more perspective I have that I want to
bring across to you besides all of this
I would also like to use this channel as
a playground to learn about social media
learn about YouTube and other platforms
like that so hanging with me here let's
not take the suit seriously I'm sharing
a few thoughts and hopefully we are
gonna learn from that of course I'm very
much open for your suggestions I would
like to hear from you what topics around
these things you would be interested in
ask me question set me up via email or
in the comments below and of course
subscribe to this channel to mass media
do not miss our any opportunity
of course over time I will also work
with improving the equipment to make
this a more professional experience for
everybody involved
so hang in there here with me as well
the audio quality will improve over time
thank you for watching this very first
video I will be posting new videos soon
so let's get started